jadini's going to appear everybody loves
jay deeney when we said yeah he's a
birthday treat jd is all nervous about
it because it's my birthday and he feels
it adds pressure to him and he goes i
don't know if i can maintain my
character voice he never does why is he
worried about this no pressure but my
birthday becomes more depressing with
every line you [ __ ] up that we worked
hard on writing our writing team was up
all night with this all right turn off
the jd become jay deeney
for my birthday
i wanted nothing more than to contact
the fear the sage
the soothsayer
a mumbling mystic
who knows all
sees all and of course eats all
join me in welcoming the wonderful great
jadini
[Music]
[Laughter]
you've already ruined what's happening
yeah oh
i'm just happy to see howard has been so
long happy birthday howard ye who
possesses secrets of the universe
except how you landed your wife
enlighten us what are your predictions
for the future o.j deeney
i predict the next pandemic will come
from whatever bacteria is floating
around in the hot tub at the bachelor
mansion
oh
[Music]
instant regret
slow down a little when you deliver all
right
okay
oh jadini
you of course have six senses and of
course three chins but please tell us
the future jadini go ahead
pete davidson will [ __ ] every hot woman
on the planet and tragically have to
move on to eights
[Music]
ye who [ __ ] up every line
tell us what we're in store for in the
coming year go ahead jd i predict that
after his latest outburst
antonio brown will be given the nfl's
most intense punishment
a five-year sentence as a member of the
new york jets
oh great one
so well do you even understand that joke
jd yes i understand it's a good job
[Music]
he who has been called hitler of humor
ah come on now as you guest chamber
every joke
go ahead
oh
i predict
taylor swift will suffer a traumatic
injury god damn it start again because
it's
taylor swift
let me predict now wait a minute let him
go
all right i
can do i predict
taylor swift will suffer great
carry
all right uh sorry i predict taylor
swift
will suffer a traumatic head injury and
will be forced to change her name
to taylor slow
to taylor slow
that's funny
it was a funny joke you could see he's
laughing buddy
oh
jay deeney who speaks of the future
but clearly not in english
jay deeney what is your next prediction
go ahead i predict
vanilla ice will sell his entire music
catalog to sony for a handful of cheese
doodles
that's a good joke
i do sabotage
[Music]
ojd you who can't even get a laugh out
of robin quivers
what is your next prediction oh i
predict a complete collapse of the
global birth rate after nick cannon
undergoes a vasectomy
oh sheet chuckle
oh thief of enjoyment oh killer of shows
i predict we will never do this again
this is the last time ever i promise
when did you start predicting
i'm predicting now you herpes of humor
go ahead i predict
the equalizer will face down her most
dangerous enemies
her most dangerous enemies yet
hyperterm hypertension
all right all right get out of here how
many more do you have i've got to give
them let me see let me count i got four
more
hold on
i'm going to cut this down right now
give me one second do the ronnie
prediction let's see how that works
i predict
ronnie
will finally admit it was a mistake to
move to las vegas when a dildo melts in
his ass
a dildo dildo delgado
a deldo
ye
jdini who says deldo instead of dildo
and ruins the joke
oh jay
yes on my birthday i've never felt older
than i do right now thank you jadini
oh jay deeney
you know let's just end it
okay that's fine there's no high
your birthday i'll do note you want
jadini the 911 of chuckles the joke
jihadist you are
the comedy auschwitz on my birthday that
just occurred i apologize maybe next
year you know what i'd like to try on my
birthday rondini
[Laughter]
oh rondini let's meet here again same
time same station
you